[MUSIC]
Hello everyone, my name is Elisa,
I am a member of the MBA admissions
team here at the Stanford GSB.
I'm joined by three panelists and we hope
to have a fourth joining during this time,
and we're excited to have you here
today to talk about preparing for
a career in education and impact.
How things are going to go today is
we have about 55 minutes together.
I'm going to give you a brief
introduction to the Stanford GSB,
to our global community.
I will introduce you to our panelists,
I have some questions for
them to start our conversation.
But you also have a chance in
the Q&A pod as we start speaking or
if there's something particular
that you would like answered today.
Feel free to ask questions along the way,
and
I will do my best to moderate, and
make sure your questions get answered.
So again, I want to thank all
the panelists for joining us today and
all of you also,
this is a really great turnout.
We're excited to have all of you.
So as I said,
I wanted to talk a little bit about
the global community here at the GSB.
Specifically because this is a career
focused discussion in panel today
about preparing for
a career in education and impact,
we wanted to share
the Information we have on that.
In the sense that 91% of students had
job offers from the GSB 3 months post
graduation with over 445 organizations
hiring our Stanford MBAs for
opportunities.
These could be full time or
summer opportunities.
A really interesting thing and
perhaps this is relevant to some of you on
the call today,
71% of students made a pivot.
That means they were in a certain
industry before coming to the GSB and
ended up doing something else after.
Possibly due to something
they were exposed to or
learned about while at the GSB.
So our panelists can share a little bit
more about their career path as we get
to that.
Because today specifically around impact
and education, an interesting stat here
is that 19% of those who graduate
are in the socially responsible roles,
18% started new ventures including
some of our panelists here.
And then of those new ventures,
12% actually turned out to be
in healthcare most recently.
For more information on career paths and
even just to learn about our
Career Management Center,
I encourage you all to visit our webpage.
You can search for GSB CMC,
which is one of the acronyms for
Career Management Center, and
one of the many acronyms here at
the GSB if you want to learn more.
But again, hopefully that's just a teaser
for you thinking about your career,
thinking about where the GSB might
help you or lead you on your journey.
We are joined today by
four wonderful panelists.
I'm excited to have all of them here.
Rather than me introduce each of them, I'm
going to have them introduce themselves.
So if each of you can introduce yourself,
talk about what you were doing before
the GSB and what you're doing now after or
perhaps what you've done after and
might be doing now,
because you may have done more than
one thing already after, please do so.
But I'd also like to queue
up with our first question
of in addition to introducing yourself,
please share with us perhaps what was your
most impactful experience or
memory from the GSB.
So this could be a course you took,
an extracurricular activity,
a travel experience, whatever it may be,
just what is kind of most memorable or
impactful to you during your time here.
We'll just go in order,
so starting with Anuja.
>> Hi everyone, welcome.
So my name is, Anuja Burns,
and I graduated in 2010,
as you can see, so
I've done a bunch of things.
So I went to MIT for my undergrad,
I did engineering internships,
and post MIT, I worked at BCG.
I was doing consulting and private equity.
But I knew I wanted to change.
So when I went to Stanford,
my goal was to find a job that I loved.
Post Stanford, I ended up helping
run the Internet startup, and
then I started a preschool.
So I started a preschool in 2012.
And I was so fortunate because
I sold it right before COVID,
early last year to Bright Horizons,
which is a huge public company.
And now I'm running a nonprofit and
we're working on education in India.
I'm also Coso where I work
with foster youth and
just doing a lot of volunteer work.
And to answer the question Elisa, so for
me I would say the way Stanford
has impacted me is the community.
So there's people who take the time
to get to know you, they care, and
they push your thinking.
So when I was at Stanford, I was
thinking like I want this job I love.
But I was on a very ambitious path
of prior to business school, and so
I was still in that mindset.
And so they had this opportunity
to get a prestigious
fellowship where I would be placed
at the top of a school district,
and you help implement change
in a school from above.
And I talked to my friend John, he was
in the joint degree program with me,
the education MBA joint degree program.
And I was like, John, I'm so excited.
They have this broad residency,
this is perfect for me.
And he was like, Anuja, you're crazy.
That's just consulting
in a school district.
You like working with kids.
That's what makes you happy.
Why are you going back into consulting?
I was like, you're right.
And just that one conversation that helped
me think about what I really wanted to do.
And then I did a business plan to start
a school, and I did start a school.
So I just think that community
of people who push your
thinking is very unique to Stanford.
Great, thank you.
Christina, could you
introduce yourself and
also share your most memorable
experience from the GSB?
>> Sure, hi everybody.
It is great to be here.
And as you can see, I'm the class of 2019.
I went to Amherst College for
undergrad, and I studied psychology.
And right after graduating
from college in 2013,
I taught with Teach for
America in Baton Rouge, Louisiana.
I was a 6th and 7th grade math teacher.
And after that,
I decided to go into consulting.
I was trying to make
a pivot from education and
try to kind of like hone my
business skills a little bit.
So I decided to go into consulting, and
then from there went to the GSB, thought
that I would go into education consulting
afterward or nonprofit consulting.
But I decided to pursue
the social innovation fellowship,
which I'm sure we'll talk about that
today because Claire is also a fellow.
But I received funding to launch
my own venture hope bound,
which I'm currently working on, and we
are an adolescent mental health nonprofit.
So we partner with middle schools and
high schools and
connect them with essentially
free weekly therapy for the kids.
So we focus on schools who
don't have a budget for
a school based mental health
professional on the campus.
And I've been doing that for two years,
which has been great so far.
And let's see my favorite or
one of the most impactful experiences.
It is hard to think about but the first
thing that came to mind was probably
the class Touchy Feely, which I'm
sure a lot of you all have heard of.
But for me,
I think I still think back to it.
Really often just think about a lot of the
things I learned about myself as a person,
and I actually still meet every month
with what's called the support group.
So it's two people from
your Touchy Feely group.
That you meet with over
the retreat weekend.
But anyway, it's been about two years,
as I said, and we still meet monthly.
So clearly it's had an impact on me.
So I felt like that was
a really valuable experience.
>> Great, thank you for sharing.
Claire, thanks for joining.
If you could also introduce yourself and
share with us your most memorable or
impactful experience from the GSB,
that'd be great.
>> Yeah, I'm Claire.
Thanks for having me.
I did my undergrad at Stanford and
then also taught in Louisiana.
Like Christina, I was in New Orleans,
taught high school math and
was an administrator at a school,
Public Charter High School there and
had really believed in
schools as a unit of change.
Like a lot of other panelists here,
it's really exciting to hear kind of
how everybody's gotten into the space.
And I had also just found that,
we were graduating kids and
they were dropping off after high school.
So the college persistence and
the workforce connectedness
issues felt very real.
And so I wanted to zoom out,
understand different school models, and
do the joint degree program to kind of
better understand what was going on.
Outside of K-12 and in higher ED and
then workforce development to
sort of reevaluate where the kind of
where my place of leverage might be.
To ensure that our young people were
in more stable lives in their mid 20s.
And so through the same program that
Christina referenced, I found a nonprofit
that is a national organization that
strengthens the school to work pipeline.
So we have a set of resources and advisory
support directly for young people in and
around high school.
And then we have an institutional support
practice where we help school districts
build out extension programs to help plug
some of the gaps where students fall
through the cracks.
And one of the, there are a lot
of really influential moments.
Actually think the SIF,
the Social Innovation Fund application
process was really meaningful.
I hadn't really had formal training
before with making slide decks or
pitches or trying to kind of really
clearly articulate pain points.
And all the different kind of components
of articulating where there's a need and
where I might support.
And so it felt like the one on
one support that I got through
that process was really rigorous and
really personalized.
And I don't know that I'd been
pushed to be as good of a writer and
school in the past.
So it felt like many different
pockets like that exist at school
where kind of if you take initiative,
there's a ton of support.
>> Great, thanks for sharing that.
And Daniel, if you could introduce
yourself and share your most memorable or
impactful experience, that'd be great.
And you are a recent grad so you should
[LAUGH] have that top of mind, hopefully.
>> Yes, thank you very much for
the invitation.
I'm Daniel, I'm from Colombia.
I just graduated from the MBA master
integration joint degree a month ago.
And before the GSB, I did investment
banking, two years in New York and Mexico.
And then I joined a higher education
financing startup back in Colombia.
And then, I founded a nonprofit which is
a career development mentorship program.
We help low income college students
get to decide what they want to do
with their life with software design,
your likeability, and
they help them get the best jobs.
And I did that for
years full time before coming to the US.
And I was a university professor,
adjunct professor.
And for me,
the GSB was an incredible experience and
just want to highlight
the uniqueness of the joint degree.
It's an incredible program, not only
because if you a lot of flexibility
on how you want to choose your
electives from the Ed school and
literally, there's only what we
were class on there is elected.
So you tailor it towards your interest.
Mine is education entrepreneurship and
investment.
And also from the background was
an incredible experience it was part of
the Education team.
And then learning just from all
the themes around impact investing,
moving forward, to me, it was good
investing in a Colombian tech startup.
So it was a cool experience.
And then the other highlight will
be the article Fellows Program.
I think is the most unique
program at the GSB.
It's a leading credible leadership
development program and just an intense
self-awareness introspection process
throughout the entire year of the program.
I highly suggest everyone to do it, apply,
I think it makes you a better person,
better manager, better leader.
Definitely the thing that I would
cherish the most from the experience
apart community which is incredible,
but that program was [INAUDIBLE].
>> Great, thanks for sharing Daniel.
I actually, just since you answered
about that, I do want to clarify for
everyone on.
Could you share a little bit more
about the Arbuckle fellows and
just what their role is, especially
how they mentor the first years, and
just what that role is like?
>> Sure, so
basically the first year, first,
there's a classical leadership lab where
basically we have a squad of six MBA
ones and
they are led by an MBA twos at Arbuckle.
And basically, as an MBA two,
you're trained,
it's a methodology called
collective coaching methodology,
through coaching,
through inquiry, and curiosity.
And basically, we have that for we do our
first year, we applied to the program.
Around 70 are selected,
six MBA ones per fellow.
And then we get this very intense
training where we first facilitate
this class as a fellow of the MBA ones.
And then we become coaches to three
MBA ones in our third quarter,
fifth quarter, I think,
fourth and fifth quarter.
And basically, it's an intense one on one
coaching, five or six coaching sessions
with three different MBA ones, different
than the ones from the first class.
So it's an intense coaching
program that we go through.
>> Great, thanks for explaining that
just because I have a feeling most of
the people on probably not heard
of the Arbuckle Fellows before.
So one of the questions we have
is around the joint degree,
which I think many of you did.
I know Anusia and Claire mentioned it.
I know Daniel did it.
Christina, did you, no?
Okay, so let's focus this
question then to Anusia and
Claire, if you guys could speak
to just how did your decision
process go in terms of deciding
to do the joint degree?
And did it help with your career goals,
career aspirations specifically?
So Anusia, why don't we start with you?
Yeah, sure, so it had a huge impact on my
career because through the joint degree
program is I did, I think, an independent
study with an education professor,
and that's where I did my
business plan to start my school.
So It was in one of those classes.
We had an education class,
we had a guest speaker.
And we did a case study on a woman who
started a middle school in Mountain View.
And I talked to her and she said,
I said, I want to start my own school.
This sounds so cool.
And she said, we'll do a business plan,
like work it out and
going through that process will really
help you and then you can just start one.
I said okay, so that's what I did.
And then because the GSB and
the ED school are so flexible,
you do have that opportunity to sort
of create the curriculum you want and
Looking back at my business plan I made,
I had a timeline in it.
And I think in my timeline, I said,
I would open doors September
2012 of my school, and
I ended up starting it October 2012.
So it was sort of cool that I was
able to bring this plan to life.
>> Great, thanks, Claire, do you want to
share just how you decided to do
the joint degree and
how did it help you in your career?
>> Yeah, I was pretty involved in
education and undergrad at Stanford.
So I felt like I had some
exposure to professors already.
But I came in sort of feeling, so
you can apply at the outset or
you can start your MBA and then apply,
and I had applied at the very beginning.
I think, first and foremost,
it was just a really intentional decision
that I wanted to pursue
education as a career.
And the GSB can pull you in
a lot of different directions.
And I felt like the commitment to
the ED school and to the group that was
in the joint degree program was
a really helpful anchor for me.
I felt like I made really good friends,
who we still continue to
meet in a small group.
Some are in investing,
some are working in product and
just kind of all over
the map in education.
But a really helpful set of kind
of professional friendships,
I would say, that continue to serve me.
And it was just a helpful informal space
when I was there too to be able to kind
of, like Anuja's talking about,
kind of lean on different professors,
lean on students.
And be able to explore different things
with the sort of added lens of education.
And I had previously studied education
with more of a teaching lens, and
this felt more of an organizational
lens with a couple different pathways.
Which was just sort of coming into
the business school with this idea that
I maybe wanted to think about building
a business and managing people.
It was just a helpful layer that
was more kind of industry specific.
>> Great, thanks for sharing that.
Christina, I want to gear the next
question towards you to start
with answering.
And again, any of the panelists,
feel free to chime in.
But we have a question around just
how does the GSB support you if
you are starting something
in social impact?
So if you have an idea,
but maybe not a budget.
And you mentioned already the fellowship
that you received and were part of.
So if you could share just about that.
But also in any other ways that the GSB
may have helped you on your journey
towards starting something,
specifically in social impact.
>> Yeah, definitely, so
just to share a little bit more about
the social innovation fellowship.
So each year, there are two people
that are awarded the fellowship.
And as of last year, it was only for
people launching nonprofits.
But now it's for people who are just
launching social ventures in general.
So they could be for-profit or nonprofit.
Can everyone hear me?
>> Yep.
>> I just thought that it
might have frozen, okay.
>> [LAUGH]
>> For a second,
I thought it froze because
the three faces I saw really.
So they were listening intently to me,
I guess.
So I won't go too much
into that right now.
I know that the link was
sent out in the chat and
because it is only two people each year.
I think it might serve me better to share
more about the other options as well.
So for that fellowship, however,
they do provide you $110,000 and
a year of advising to launch it.
So it's a really wonderful opportunity.
But some of the other opportunities that
could take place is one over the summer.
So if you want to test out some of your
ideas to launch your own social impact
adventure or if you want to
join one that already exists.
There's a funding that the CMC,
the Career Management Center,
as well as the center that's over social
innovation entrepreneurship provides for
you to not be concerned about the salary
that you're paid over the summer.
So they will essentially double your
salary so that it's on par with
what your other classmates would be
making in a more traditional internship.
So that's really just unique, and
I think it shows how intentional the GSB
is about trying to remove any financial
barriers to go into social impact.
Another example beyond the internships and
beyond the fellowship is
the loan forgiveness program.
So if you decide to enter
into a social impact career.
And if you are making below a certain
cutoff, and I won't quote any specific
numbers because it might have changed,
but your loans could be forgiven.
So that's just a third example
of how the GSB really does take
the budget part of it that was
mentioned in the question into account.
>> Great, thanks for sharing,
that's really helpful I think for
those on the call to hear that.
And just to chime in a little
bit about loan forgiveness,
I also am not going to say an exact number
just because that always can change.
But I encourage you if you want
to learn about that program,
it is something that is offered.
So were you to come to the GSB and
take on loans and
then go work in a nonprofit or
in the public sector.
You could be eligible then for this loan
forgiveness program, which again is one
of the ways that the GSB is committed to
helping those pursue careers in this area.
So I do want to jump, there was
a question and they're interchanging.
But there was one
specifically around clubs or
extracurriculars that may have
helped kind of shape you or
exposed you to certain ideas or
people or things throughout.
So if you could speak to, and
we'll start with Daniel, what clubs or
extracurriculars you may have been
involved in that also kind of helped you
on your path towards social impact or
education?
>> [COUGH] I think, as I mentioned,
I think our rubble fellows, impact fund,
and joint degree, those three things,
it's a big commitment already.
Then the other ones, Education Club
is a nice social thing to basically
meet people from the GSB interchange
education from the ED school.
That are also I think they can join, and
basically a newsletter of things related,
job opportunities and
just information on education.
Then everything related to
the Social Innovation Center,
especially that having good relation.
Yeah, like an advisor that you can,
like for me was Naomi Beyer, for example.
And just having regular catches with her,
just to her the things I was doing.
And she always try to connect me
with people that were relevant, so
I mean stuff that was
relevant to my interest.
At the end, yeah,
I think joining a club is good,
because you'll see who are people
interested in the theme.
But at the end, literally, you can
do many things outside of a club and
just literally doing independent projects.
Or working outside part time,
or doing an internship, or
doing a special part with any
institution you're interested.
For example, with the impact fund,
the advisor of the impact fund is
Hall Ventures,
which is the largest set of VC funds.
They advise education
the under mostly GSB years.
And just getting to know them
from the impact fund, I'd say, or
however you guys to help you open,
invest in Latin America.
That was one of the most
vocal experiences for me.
And I got credit for that and I just got
an incredible relationship with them and
learn a lot from them.
So I think just knowing that
while you were a student and
under GSB credential are just huge.
To get the amount of returns
that come to you and
you can do on the side
are literally unique.
So I would highly encourage everyone
to be creative and think, okay,
what am I interested in?
What institutions are the people
want to reach out?
And why am I unique in my theme?
And just tell a good story to get and
create the opportunity that you
want based under your interest.
>> Hey, thanks, Claire, could you
chime in and share maybe a club or
extracurricular that influenced you or
helped you during your time at the GSB.
>> Yeah, I actually didn't
formally joined a lot of clubs.
I sort of didn't want to be spread
too thin and so I focused a lot
on taking a lot of classes across
the GSB and the school of education.
And I went to a lot of office hours,
sort of got a good read,
these are sort of informal
things to get involved in.
But got a good read quickly on kind of
which professors were really invested in
student growth.
And then I did a few different independent
studies and internships as kind
of mini tests to answer a couple
questions for myself about my career.
So, did I want to start my own school?
Did I want to start a school
from within the network?
What were different models?
How could I do projects with those types
of institutions to really get to know
them with professors that would help me
kind of pull apart some different themes.
And then I spent a lot
of time getting to know
my classmates and
trying to carve out time to
sort of learn more about their background.
I sort of only knew teaching and
working in schools and
learned a ton from other
people's experiences.
In terms of how to build or not build
culture across different industries,
just sort of things like that
from informal conversations.
And I found the summer internship
program through Smith that Christina,
I think, referenced really,
really useful because that was
a subsidized nonprofit internship.
I worked for a venture philanthropy
fund that supported schools, so
it was a better chance for
me to kind of understand 30,000 but
few did that feel engaging and
meaningful to me.
And was part of a kind of network of
classmates who had also participated
in that program.
So that felt like a good way to sort
of pressure test some things and
have some folks to be
able to reflect with.
But I think sort of throughout
it was either formal or
informal ways to just have
conversations with people.
And use the opportunity to be
more self-reflective that I
didn't feel like I had when I was working
and more kind of focused on my job.
>> Great, thanks.
Christina, could you share if there was,
I guess, an experience whether
it's extracurricular club related
that also helped you along the way?
If it's been already mentioned
you can say that, [LAUGH] too.
>> Yeah, I mean, I think honestly I
would say I am like clear where I was.
I don't know if it came from being
burned out as a teacher in the past.
But I just really wanted to conserve
my energy and be intentional, so
I didn't really join any clubs.
The one extra club in which I was
really involved was the BBSA, so
the black business student association.
So there's tons of different
affinity groups and
I was able to help lead the revival of
the annual conference when I was there.
So I think that was a really great
experience in just leadership,
public speaking,
dealing with logistics and
operations which has served me
well now running my own business.
But I would say the one other
thing I will make a note of,
it was a class but
it's called social ventures practicum.
So it's kind of like startup garage,
which you all may have heard of, but
it's focused on social
ventures in particular.
And I actually was able to recruit six
different students from all across
the Stanford campus undergrad,
different grad programs to
help work on idea for hope.
And that was my first time really
being able to manage people.
It was quite an interesting experience,
learned a lot of things so
that I could be a lot better at it now.
But they just want to note that, but
I would say no other specific
clubs as related to social impact.
>> Christina, I have a question, was the
social venture practicum one quarter or
was that over multiple quarters?
>> Yeah, there's over one quarter and
it was taught by two professors one
Bill Yuan who was more of
like a consulting background.
And another one Kim Starkey now and
she's focused more on philanthropy.
So it was a really interesting
combination of the two.
>> Great, thanks for sharing.
We have a question and that's been kind
of up voted to know what is it that
caught you most off guard when
you started business school?
So what has surprised
you most about the GSB?
And you can feel free to answer that, I'll
probably start with Daniel since you're
the most recent graduate of the program.
But I also want to for many of our
panelists, for many of you it was a change
in terms of coming to business school
from what you were doing before.
And there is another question, so
feel free to kind of what surprised you?
But also in your first year,
maybe share what that adjustment was like.
So in addition to your surprise what
helped you adjust to being in business
school especially if you were
pivoting from a different industry?
So again, we'll start with Daniel.
>> Sure, [COUGH] so I think that the
intensity of the first couple quarters,
everything, it's a lot
of things basically.
And there's a lot of incredible
unique opportunity you think
that every coffee chat, every BBL events
in the afternoons, every speaker.
They're all like probably one of the most
unique experience I've ever had to meet
this person or hear this person talk.
So if any of you are intellectually
curious and like different things it'll,
[LAUGH] be a muscle of practicing
when you really understand.
Okay, what am I here for and
what am I going to spend my limited time?
And that involves personal stuff,
friends, classes,
BBLs, and working on independent
products so that's the first thing.
Then the first year classes are very,
well,
it depends on the level on the other and
experience each version comes with.
But they could be the more traditional,
the one that the way you think and
have the kind of a core curriculum and
things that you got to go through.
For me I started kind of working part
time since second quarter probably.
And basically it was really good that at
the ending the grades of
the GSB don't matter that much.
If you want to do great, you can go and
try to be an Arbuckle fellow, sorry,
an Archie Miller which is like top 10%.
But if you just want to
pass you can only pass.
I think that's one of the misconception
is that it's very hard.
The classes are hard, and you have to
get good grades and you got to study and
do a bunch of stuff.
But if you just want to pass and
focus on certain classes.
Or in others maybe don't focus much and
just do the bare minimum because you
want to put your time
to non academic stuff.
You can do it and that gives you a lot
of freedom and I think that makes
the community be much stronger and
the people want it to help each other.
I never felt any type of
competitiveness in terms of,
my classmates in the class,
just helping each other and
I think that's great and that.
After the first quarter because first,
you got to get your first classes and
make sure that you pass
on your neck operation.
After the first quarter.
I never felt kind of a lot of
stress in terms of academics.
I think that's a huge thing for.
>> Hey, thanks for sharing.
And I'd love for each of the panellists to
answer this just what has surprised you
most and then maybe any tips or
learnings from your first year.
So in Asia, why don't we go
around at least how I see you
guys would echo [LAUGH]
>> Yeah a lot of what Daniel said, but for
me, I do remember thinking
it was quite rigorous.
It was much busier than I was expecting,
because I don't know if people still say
it, but people would say, Business School,
is sort of a vacation, or
it's fun, or something.
A lot of people come when
you're coming from finance, and
working these 80 hour weeks, I thought
Cool, I'm burnt out I need a break.
But it was still incredibly busy.
But in a much different way in
a much more engaging way, a fun way.
And in there's classes and there's parties
and clubs and just have everything
travel experiences and my classmates
they're like, hey, it's Tuesday.
Let's go to Vegas for the night.
Come back on Wednesday.
I don't know if it's still the same.
But balancing all of that and
getting over this FOMO right?
The fear of missing out and learning how
to really focus your efforts on the people
you want to spend time with in the classes
you want to spend time with and the trips.
Just because everyone's going
to the World Cup doesn't
mean you have to go and so
I think that was not overwhelming.
But maybe and then once you figure it out,
you have your core group you
learn more about who you are.
And then I think those
are the friendships and
relationships you take with
you when you leave the GSB.
>> Christina, could you share?
>> Yeah, I feel like I could just
say ditto to all that, honestly.
Yeah, I think for me, I was really
taken aback by just how busy it was.
I remember it was the first time that
I was really glued to my calendar.
And it's like, kind of funny thinking back
to it, but like Daniel was talking about
the coffee chats and all that, but even
the social things are on your calendar.
Like everyone just sends
a calendar invite for everything.
And I wasn't used to that before.
So it was the kind of thing
where it was like, all right.
It's Monday at 10am.
Let me check my calendar to remind
myself what am I doing at 1pm today.
So it was very busy but
in a good way, very exciting,
so many different unique opportunities,
but
it kind of felt like Constant activity.
So I think the first year I kind of
did let myself like Claire mentioned,
you get pulled a lot of
different directions.
I let myself get pulled a lot
of different directions.
That second year,
I was able to be more intentional and
figure out what I wanted to say yes to.
So that's what I would say kind of,
echoing the same theme
that's been shared so far.
>> Great and Claire, could you also chime
in if there's anything else to add in
terms of what surprised you and any tips
in your first year that you learned?
>> Yeah.
Probably two big things.
One I had a really hard time with
the fact that it felt like I had
gone from this place where
everything I did was so
other people could be successful to
being like only worried about myself.
And Grad school is just like very self
indulgent and that's wonderful and
I think I just took me a little while
to name that and feel okay about it.
And I think once I sort of was like this
is just a different time in your life and
you're here to learn so that you can
be more useful to people in the future.
That was a sort of helpful
mindset shift for me.
But I think because of what these folks
have said around just being so busy.
It's easy to sort of be distracted and
not not give yourself enough time to pay
attention to kind of how you're
feeling about the transition.
And then the second thing is that I
found the core classes really hard.
And I was acutely aware of what good
teaching looked like and I was sort of
like lectures are really hard for
me to learn in and I don't know that.
I'm absorbing all the sort of financial
literacy that I came here to learn.
And a lot of folks in the class
know a lot more than I do.
And so I felt a little bit insecure
actually in the beginning.
And, I think,
over time started to feel like okay,
this is part of a larger experience.
I'm learning these things.
They're new to me.
That's okay.
And, also some of the other
people management things and
EQ things that have more exposure to and
managing other adults,
classrooms or things that are going to
be relevant at some point.
And so
I think it was just sort of being okay
with being challenged and feeling like.
I think if I were to give some
advice around that it's just sort of
like trusting the process and
sort of feeling like.
Even if you don't feel really
confident in the moment that your
strengths will play out in different
ways across the two years or three or
however long you spend
earning your degree.
>> Great, thanks for sharing.
We have a question around
global experience.
And specifically whether any of you did
pursue or fulfill your global experience
requirement with a focus on social
impact or education, which I don't know.
But I'd love for
some of you to share about that.
So, Christina,
could you share what you did to fulfill
your global experience requirement?
And actually before you answer, just for
everyone on the call because
this was a question.
Some of you might be wondering what
is the global experience requirement,
which you can Google and find more.
Out more, you can find about
more information online.
But briefly, there's a requirement for
those who come to
the GSB to spend time in a country they've
never lived in or worked in before.
And this can be fulfilled in many
different ways from a global study trip to
another acronym called a G Max,
which is a one month internship.
So I'm going to just throw that
out there just to clarify for
those on the call who maybe
didn't know what that is.
And so Christina, if you could share what
how did you fulfill your global experience
for permanent that'd be great.
>> Sure, so
I went to Greece which was amazing.
When during the springtime,
and I think Greece and
who knows there might be someone on
here from there, but at least to me,
I just thought of it as okay,
this beautiful tourist destination.
But what we focus on what we learned
about was how the debt crisis
has Impacted by the inequity in
health care for Greek people.
So it was extremely eye opening and
I would say it was related to I ultimately
decided That accessibility when
it comes to mental health was really
important to me, and that's something
I didn't see in the students that I
work with every day as a teacher.
So I think it just opened my eyes to
basically, how when there is a debt
crisis, how tourism tries to kind of
offset some of those impacts, but
who really ends up getting impacted
the most are the people who live there.
And that Healthcare as challenging
as it can be in the United States
is definitely not something to
be taken for granted at all.
So yeah,
it was a very interesting experience.
>> Great, could any of the other
panelists, I can pick on you, but
anyone want to share
their global experience?
>> I can share mine.
So I went to Thailand and Cambodia, and
we were focused on human trafficking.
So it was pretty intense.
And part of the global study trip we
were actually passing out condoms in
the red light district in Thailand.
And I was able to talk to sex workers and
just really understand all
the societal factors and
everything that went into these people's
lives, and it was really interesting.
And I was part of a club at the GSB.
We were focused on human trafficking and
ways we can help, and
so super interesting.
And I think what has stuck with me is
just meeting people who were similarly
passionate and who cared, and
having these conversations was incredible.
>> Great, thanks, Daniel, could you
share maybe how things changed for
global experiences?
Specifically, travel was impacted
in the past year with COVID, so
could you share how you fulfilled
a global experience requirement?
>> I was very lucky because I did
mine in December of my first year.
So I went to Brazil and
did an entrepreneurship study trip,
but then I did my summer.
I was going to go to Brazil to work for a
private K-12 network, and then to Colombia
to work for a nonprofit charter school,
and had to do both virtually.
So I did SMIF, Social Management
Innovation Fellowship, I think.
Basically, it's a stipend that they
gave me, I think $1,300 a week for
ten weeks, and later they paid me for
me to work with these two organizations.
I stayed, I was under recovery,
I stayed in Palo Alto and
worked virtually from there.
I got a lot of, maybe half of my class
pre-COVID fulfilled their study trip,
and then the others did
virtual experiences.
Yeah, I think two, three day virtual
sessions with some of the speakers that
were going to be in the country, speak in
the country where they were going to go.
But I would say, hopefully everyone
can all travel in the next year or
in the next few years.
But I think the global study trips
are just an incredible experience
because they're very well run,
not only logistically, but
the quality of the speakers
is just incredible.
And the MBA2s lead the study trips,
and they put a lot of work into it,
and most of the leader
are either from that country or
are very interested in that country.
And then the ideas we have and
just facilitates a lot of the alumni
networks to get the best speakers,
the best of the best speakers, and
experiences in those trips,
and you have a lot of fun.
There's some partying involved and
everything,
so it's just a great combination of,
these are 30 student trips.
So you create a great bond with
the people that go to the trips.
>> Great, thanks for sharing.
Claire, could you share how you fulfilled
your global experience requirement?
>> Yeah, I went to Singapore in Indonesia,
and our trip was focused
on ride sharing and ride hailing and
the growth of the gig economy.
And so fairly different from
different sort of maybe
education-focused initiatives.
And actually in reflecting on different
classes that I found most valuable at
school, some of them were just completely
different from anything that I had known
previously.
And I think actually exposure to
stuff in the for profit sector and
in different pockets just really
helped me push my thinking.
And kind of one of the reasons I
went to school in the first place is
because I didn't know what I didn't know.
And so I actually think looking back,
it's sort of crazy the sort of people and
things that you're exposed to, people in
different places of power and government.
Talked a ton about how politics influences
different business decisions in Indonesia,
where there are different sort
of pockets of corruption.
And just sort of thinking about,
I was also thinking about the politics
of education reform, and just different
ways that they had approached challenges
felt like a useful kind of new lens.
>> Great, thanks for sharing.
And there is one question, and
I think Daniel, you were involved in this,
you mentioned the social impact fund.
If you could just share a little
bit more about what that is and
how as a student you can
get involved in that.
Is it a course or
is it more treated like a club?
If you could just share a little
bit about the social impact then.
>> Sure, so
it's a club that you have to apply.
I think last year was, I think, SMIF,
there's seven groups within the fund,
education, healthcare, fintech, etc.
There's seven groups, and
each group has between six and
seven students,
who are mostly first years.
Each group is led by an MBA2.
And basically, I think last year
the acceptance rate was 30% or 20%.
A lot of people applied.
It's an incredible investing experience,
the most similar thing to VC.
So you apply in November,
December of your first year, and
you have to enter with your team leader.
Each team leader creates their own group,
and they basically go through
the entire experience of
sourcing companies in your field.
So you talk with funds that
invest in education, so
with all the education VCs for
them to send you deals.
And basically, you define a theme
within the group, you internally,
you talk with the founders, and then you
decide which ones you want to invest, and
then you vote in turn as a group.
And the top two startups,
these are early stages, are seed and
series A startups that are raising funds.
And then the top two
startups with every group,
you take them to an investment committee.
An investment committees is composed
by some faculty members and
just very experienced investors in
the impact investment community.
And then you pitch those to investment
committee and then everyone votes,
both the investment committee members and
the other team members.
So the good thing is that you
go through the entire process.
Even if your deal or the company
you're pitching, if they don't pass,
you see the entire thing, the entire
process of everyone pitching and
the back and forth of questions between
the investment committee members and
the people from the fund.
And at the end, the fund chooses between
two and four startups every year,
and they get a $50,000 investment,
more or less.
And actually, a lot of people do that, and
then they have the experience to
then get a job in impact investing.
Or in venture capital.
So I think it's the best way for those
that want to get into an investing role,
is just the most incredible way to do it.
And then get a summer job at a farm.
And then hopefully you get
a full-time offer, those GSB.
>> Okay, thanks for
sharing more about that.
We have five minutes left together.
I want to pose one more
question to all four panelists,
which is asked by someone in the audience,
named Brandon, who just said,
what do you wish you did while at the GSB?
Do you have any regrets?
So, is there anything you, I don't know,
wish you had done more of or
just had more time to do because I know
time is always the biggest commodity here.
But I'd love for
each of you to just quickly go around and
share whether there is something you wish
you had done more of while you were here.
So, Anuja, why don't we start with you?
>> I think, well, after hearing Daniel
talk so glowingly and all the Arbuckle
fellows, it's like, man, I wish I did
that because I just felt like I was so
busy with the joint degree program, but
coaching and sort of that reflection and
all these sorts of skills I think are so
valuable.
And there are things that am learning
now that has helped me immensely in my
personal life and that work.
And so if I was able to learn more
of those leadership skills and
that sort of the coaching model at the
GSB I think that would have been cool.-
>> Great, Christina.
>> Yeah, so I would say there
any other introverts out there,
I actually do regret not socializing.
I wish I could have found a way to make
it feel like more sustainable for me.
I think I'm not the kind of person that
would go out on a Tuesday night but
I know there were other
people like me too.
So I think I definitely have a handful of
really good friends, but I think there
are more people that were different than
me that I've had gotten to know better.
So I wish I would have gotten out of my
comfort zone a little bit on the social
front for sure.
>> Claire?
>> There are a couple classes called,
for example,
startup garage that help train
you in this sort of framework for
understanding pain points and developing.
Maybe I can send some info to the chat.
Going through the sort of product
design process for need finding.
And I think I, at sort of different
junctures in evolving our business,
I have wished that I had a better
understanding of doing UX research and
really precisely following
a process where we are.
Understanding what the need is and where
there are opportunities for us to support.
And so I would encourage even if you don't
think you want to pursue entrepreneurship.
There are some really, really high quality
classes around like lean Launchpad as
well around just kind of what
you need to start a business or
how you start to understand pin points
that seem to be really relevant now.
And I sort of wish I had taken
more advantage of them then.
>> Great and Daniel,
I know you just completed your degree but
anything you already wish you had
done while you were in school?
>> Yeah, the last year was crazy.
But the unfortunate thing for COVID is
that we it was just more difficult to meet
more people, especially the people that
I didn't got close to in the first year.
So it is typically our class is 420
people and then the class below,
up below and above.
This takes a lot of people to meet there,
a lot of incredible people, and,
yeah, for me real regret is kind of
staying with the kind of the groups or
the people that I met in the first year.
So I would encourage everyone just to
try to reach out as much as possible.
Whatever time you want to put into that,
I just every person is incredibly special.
And they getting to the GSB there's
something really unique about them.
And for me what I always thought was,
I want to meet that person and
try to understand what makes that
person unique because the admissions
are something special in that person.
And every time the more
you mean you're like,
meet with the quality of of
the people that come to this place.
>> Thank you so much for sharing.
I want to thank all four of you for
joining us today.
This was an amazing panel and
I know I learned a lot.
I hope that everyone who
attended learned a lot.
I'm sharing my screen one more time
just to encourage everyone who is on to
continue your journey at my Stanford.MBA.
Where you can learn more about clubs,
courses,
you can start to track your
application if you are applying.
Our deadlines for
the next year are already posted.
And I also encourage you if you're joining
us today to look at our list of events for
more panels.
If you're interested in specifically
admissions information,
we have information sessions
offered throughout the summer also.
So again, I want to just thank
all the panelists for joining us.
I want to thank all of you,
wherever you may be in the world,
again for joining us for this session.
We appreciate your time and
hope to see you again soon.
Thank you, everyone.
[MUSIC]